[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another episode
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we'll be discussing Voldemort's heritage
or more specifically his blood relation
to a certain other character you may
know if you don't know the story of the
Deathly Hallows well you should probably
do your homework but for the sake of the
video I'll give you a brief summary the
tale of the Deathly Hallows tells the
story of three brothers Antioch Cadmus
and egg notice the brothers were all
members of the famous Peveril family the
plot surrounds the three wizard brothers
and their ability to cheat death for a
short period of time after conquering
death a personification of death under
the guise of congratulating them awarded
them with three gifts the Elder Wand
the resurrection stone and the
invisibility cloak long story short each
brother chose one of the gifts the death
had presented them big notice the
youngest chose the invisibility cloak
Cadmus the middle brother chose the
resurrection stone and Antioch the
eldest chose the Elder Wand
death eventually found Antioch who chose
the Elder Wand and Cadmus who chose the
resurrection stone buttock notice who
chose the invisibility cloak was able to
avoid death by hiding in his cloak
something very interesting that you may
not know about the story however is that
Valda more is actually related to the
brother who chose a resurrection stone
Cadmus though it is a distant relation
we know a few things that can help us
make this connection the main one being
that Voldemort's grandfather Marvolo
gaunt possessed a ring that was passed
down in the family for generations the
ring contained the symbol of the Hallows
inscribed on a stone
and this stone is of course the same one
that Cadmus possessed so while it
originated with Cadmus it was passed
down through generations of the gaunt
family what is even more interesting
however is that egg notice the youngest
brother and recipient of the
invisibility cloak was actually the
relative of none other than Harry Potter
we know that the invisibility cloak was
passed down to Harry from his father but
what wasn't originally revealed was that
the same cloak was passed down over
generations starting with IgG notice so
if it notices and Cadmus of brothers
then that of course means that Voldemort
and Harry Potter are actually related
isn't it ironic that mortal enemies was
such opposing agendas turned out to both
be descendants of the Peverill the only
thing stopping Voldemort from world
domination was his cousin another
argument that I've heard for them being
related is the fact that Voldemort used
Harry's blood in his regeneration potion
Voldemort in his crippled state utilized
the regeneration potion to restore his
strength and form a statue this potion
of course requires bone or father flesh
of servant and global foe this but of
course being Harry's the problem with
this argument is that they are already
related so it wouldn't have made them
any more related also I'm not sure that
regenerating your body with someone
else's blood it makes you related to
them if I got a blood transfusion I
wouldn't be related to that person
anyway all you need to know is that
Harry and Voldemort are distant cousins
and both descendants of the perils
that's all for this video I hope you
enjoyed it if you did please give the
video a like to support the channel if
you have any questions or video ideas
leave them down below until next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]